the streets of Madrid are a tough beat
for buskers competition is fierce the
musicians foreign and Spanish are
crawling all over each other on the web
that s all times are hard and everyone
needs money among the musicians is the
duo called potato omelette by trade
Lauda Nadal is a piano teacher but she
can't get by on what she makes giving
lessons they're easy going good time
sounds are technically illegal they
don't have the official permit that
Buster's need to perform on Madrid
streets these days and to get it they'd
have to audition at Madrid's cultural
center as unique Mandela bream it's
humiliating to have someone judge
whether you're good enough to play in
the streets the principle of the streets
of course is survival if nobody gives
you money you're better off staying at
home and see no dinero novela gaya
autumn is more suddenly the ones who
don't have a permit are illegal as if
they were picked pockets Jonathan doors
they can slap you with a 750 euro fine
for doing is a malted estas haciendo
siguiente rose madrid city hall the
palacio de bellas is responsible for
setting the police on the buskers
for two years now ana botella wife of
spain's former prime minister jose maria
aznar has been mayor the conservative
ana botella spa polarity ratings have
been falling partly because she rarely
misses an opportunity for a gaffe even
on the issue of busking you seen our
African alamosa governor I'm a great
music lover but it's just not the same
in a concert hall or the Opera as being
on the streets normally there are street
musicians and there are street musicians
I por lo tanto inoperable as a lark I
yet i will sustain this but ana botella
spalla sees have yet to reveal any great
love of music of any kind methley leno's
have been protesting against her cuts in
the city's arts budgets
Madrid is deep in debt and has to cut
spending and the arts are almost always
the first to feel the pain
spontaneous demonstrations are almost a
daily occurrence in Madrid there have
been thousands since the crisis began
now City Hall has decided to crack down
on the protesters even harder than on
the buskers with fines of up to six
hundred thousand euros for illegal
demonstrations in front of parliament or
politicians residences much like its
policy on busking the partido popular
seems to have made its new law to
squelch protests liberal spaniards are
horrified nosotros como fuertes estamos
muy preocupados muy judges are very
concerned because we say the government
should discuss issues with the people in
social conflict situations rather than
punish their resistance through laws
that aterrizar Vegas one of the
initiators of the mass protests in Spain
the 15th of May movement is claiming the
proposed laws would curtail freedom of
speech and the extreme penalties would
effectively bypass the justice system
and they would give police free rein to
crush protests any way they see fit no
see no mess communitarian of a
communitarian maybe interment a Bobbitt
persona of course many people will be
more afraid to take to the streets while
others are well aware of what this
government's trying to do and they feel
all the more motivated to demonstrate
it's epidemic in Italian salgan out the
buskers louder and girardeau even see
the government's heavy-handed approach
as a danger if the vice case Latino don
t we go things in this country have been
relatively peaceful so far and people
have behaved well but we may soon be
seeing a much stormier wilder form of
protest on the streets of spain DeMars
must have a feel
and the potato omelette band plays on
with or without a permit